56 goddamn seconds of logos also Comcast
discount Bryan Mills slow-motion
alcoholism I guess this subtracts new
meaning to the term IRA Sheen up your
coffee Liam Neeson's character has
family members he super cares about
cliche isn't this cgi airplane moving
way too fucking slow considering Neeson
is walking at a normal pace indicating
this is not a slow-motion shot movies
have taught me anything then this random
asshole asking for a light is going to
be some manner of important player in
the drama were about to see on pole
career a full body scanner detects the
color of Liam Neeson's blood Julianne
Moore is in hiring Amanda ciphered to
flee a Mesa in this movie when this girl
travels she carries all the backpacks ah
because he returned the teddy bear we
the audience can rest easy knowing he's
the good guy even though he's obviously
an antisocial alcoholic what are the
odds at a large airport you'd be on the
same plate and the same row as the guy
you were next to at the TSA line I'm
sorry I'm on your way again also you
were talking on the phone and not moving
at all so yes speak English that's
racist
wait Neeson clearly entered the aircraft
from in front of the black dude but this
shot shows the boarding doors behind the
section they're seated it did enjoy a
gentle walk as she brought your water my
lucky day well that isn't suspicious at
all this movie came out in 2014 this
phone is unacceptable movie
intentionally keeps main characters
objectives in the dark for the
audience's sake alone superstitions how
old's your daughter now she's uh 17 it's
spooky how much this movies creators
want you to think you're watching a
taken movie and shameless what do you do
for a living well
I fly a lot well that isn't suspicious
at all people who put their seats back
on airplanes people who kick the backs
of the airplane seats in front of them
this airline offers free in-flight
boning going to the bathroom for a
mile-high smoke why wouldn't you take
your badge and gun out for absolutely no
reason whatsoever 15 minutes in this is
exactly what we're all doing right now
probably with even more power okay so
either this bad guy has cameras in the
bathroom in which case gross or the bad
guy could somehow tell bill smoked a
cigarette in the bathroom without a
flight attendant being able to tell they
texture is vague for dramatic texting
purposes why not 200 million this is the
most entertaining texting
auto-completion
ever committed to film hijacker only
believes in sending texts one sentence
at a time and someone on this flight is
threatening to kill a passenger unless
150 million dollars is transferred in
the next 18 minutes well when you say it
out loud like that it sounds kind of
stupid any threat to an aircraft
requires immediate landing yeah all
right if there is a friend bill probably
should conclude that his partner is a
bad guy from that stupid line alone this
juice fast omen gives me the shakes
well that isn't suspicious at all while
discussing a possible imminent threat to
the aircraft let's completely ignore
this obviously eavesdropping flight
attendant wait what why do you trust
either of them it expects this to work
okay anyone you can actually see right
now can also see you
which means you're stupid that takes
white racists didn't circle this guy at
the very start also no one has drawn a
dick on this guy's face somehow hacking
the network and texts that could only
come from someone on the plane isn't
enough evidence to take action and why
doesn't bill get the other marshal on
the phone what's he afraid he's gonna do
say bill didn't get those texts you son
of a bitch bill doesn't lock the door
during this confrontation meaning any
asshole on the plane that needs to go
peepee you can stroll right in and
witness these assholes have enough room
for a fistfight in an airplane bathroom
I'm sending the number of empty seats on
this plane and I don't care if it's an
overnight international flight to
Siberia no plane flying today has this
many empty seats they simply don't
scheduled flights anymore in any way
other than one that leaves them all
fully booked with a dozen poor assholes
left stranded by overbooking okay the
only possible villain candidate left at
this point is God I shoulda just called
this movie non-stop texting
no me you not never wait pilots are
casual friends with undercover air
marshals how is this possible no reason
why we can't do this out the open all
the time lost like five phones at six
months night learn this little trick
thankfully this trick conveniently knows
a way to revive submerged bones as a
passenger don't have the right to know
what's going on ha ha ha you have
clearly never flown before
and glad we could get the amazingly
realistic graphics of the cracked glass
during this texting sequence ooh
so they could sensor the part of the
text now whose sensors the word anyway
then amazingly the screens cracks cue a
different direction when they don't need
to censor anything I was looking for
agent Hammond what's wrong because
saying agent Hammond is dead in this
lavatory is in no way less traumatic for
this trip than seeing a surprise dead
body you know me well I suppose that
explains why she brought him water
instead of the drink he ordered upon
takeoff but Jesus what is the point of
undercover air marshals at the flight
attendants and pilots all know them well
enough to know that they wouldn't be
murderers just as recently instituted
the policy of rapid searches aboard
international flights illegal search and
seizure well you should know the answer
to that
meanwhile on the outside of the plane
some of us need to get some sleep sir
sit down be quiet in the communal
disavow it took all of 40 seconds for
this guy to challenge an Air Marshal a
second time after being told to sit down
very brothers getting married to a guy
with a British accent that's double
racist
so now after seemingly checking every
other passenger bill just quits after
this dude which makes it pretty
convenient timing for the bad guy to
text him right that police brutality
you've set up Stan bill has been
checking everyone's phone on this flight
all except the one guy who ends up being
the most important
Hey convenient turbulence gives godlike
bad-guy the upper hand as bill drops his
gun oh yeah liam neeson is about to drop
another badass line like the one from
take here we go from one cop to another
yeah man is that it that is some bolt
right there right the screenwriter go
damn with 150 people on this flight he's
gonna have to reduce the kill time to
like 5 minutes otherwise it would take
two days or more for that scenario a few
of the captain any reason to unlock this
door
of course mama sides the two times bill
had you unlock it right did you forget
about those copilot opens the door 30
goddamn seconds after Bill Tilden the
store stays locked until this plane
airline is obviously not owned by Sony
should I see my phone agent logs agent
marks his guilt trip by the hot flight
attendant into not checking her phone
guy we find out as a hijacker later who
knows intricate details about phones and
shit and who was supposed to be sitting
right next to bill on this flight
somehow doesn't raise a red flag to the
guy who notices everything
situation damn dude just get back on the
intercom if you're gonna tell everyone
what's up air marshal up to now about
35,000 feet time for all the vices he'll
only notices this airflow thing because
he's breaking the rules by smoking in
the boys room he's only a hero because
he's such a fuckup something tells me
this guy's YouTube documentary is gonna
have very important information bill
needs but more importantly get millions
and millions of views and YouTube watch
time do you know if someone else went in
there after you yes
she was standing there blocking the
aisle of course this woman doesn't know
the other woman's name but this is still
the pronoun game and now bill has to ask
what the hell she means what FBI or
airline protocol would allow the live
television broadcast feeds to continue
in the cabin during what is obviously
now considered a hijacking super
important character backstory delivered
via news broadcast
I love how everyone on this plane is
watching not only the news but the same
fucking channel these passengers were
crazy belligerent when they thought bill
was a good guy violating their rights
now they think he's hijacking the plane
and no one wants to confront it he'll
think I blocked the bathroom when he
goes in but they decide to sit tight
and this guy's sleeping how did these
terrorists know that the other marshals
smuggle drugs on the side you have to a
somehow find an undercover Air Marshal
and be somehow someway find the one that
is likely to smuggle drugs on an
airplane and see find the guy who was
also partners with the other guy who has
personal problems also how did they know
that they could plant a bomb inside the
cocaine and the security would let that
slide despite the fact that we saw bill
himself go through security and air
marshals probably have only a couple
things they can by rule get on a plane
oh now they decide to go for the attack
you had him in a confined area also damn
man did that fire extinguisher not hurt
one bit have you ever seen the movie
irreversible if not don't ever watch it
just take my word for it I'm not a good
father not a good man this speech works
somehow I check this play
I'm clients are safer since we know that
this dude is one of the bad guys why
didn't he just kick this gun under the
seat somewhere so that bill could never
find it
everyone on the ground thinks he's a
hijacker so he doesn't need bill to be
waving a gun anymore to back up that
narrative I am thinking well I am still
thinking about how quickly you and
everyone else switched teams to support
this asshole a few seconds ago sorry
about the nose
I was never my best feature you guys are
BFFs now that was like literally four
minutes ago he did that to your nose you
know sweetheart you've got to come out
adult on a plane with a bomb on it we
Stein conversing this girl out of a
hiding spot she could easily just be
grabbed out up I'm certain he wants to
show girls like you until my alcoholism
drove her to cancer
don't worry see your father's uncapable
promises this international flight
allows youtube uploads I can't even
watch YouTube videos on domestic flights
and even if YouTube is somehow unblocked
this plane has connection speeds able to
upload video without it taking seven
hours isn't it great that this asshole
ended up in the perfect spot to capture
something so important and that's not
even his original seat do you have any
idea how easy this was well sneaking
cocaine bomb two terrorists on the plane
somehow commandeering a secure air
marshals cell phone service creating
blow-dart weapons and finding peepholes
in the bathroom seems like it would have
been damn near impossible actually but
whatever I'm just ready for credits
3,000 people died that day including my
father
this guy blames air marshals for 9/11
man there were only 33 in service that
day I'm blowing up a plane and framing
an Air Marshal is gonna make everything
better somehow
with one minute and 56 seconds to go
this bomb takes 57 seconds to hit the
one minute and 30 second mark I'm not
gonna kill all these people this is a
hijacked flight we're a classified
threat to ground how do the hijackers
not know this this is anti-terrorism 101
sad you and I both know we're never
getting off this plane let's talk about
the terrorist plan first off how did two
completely different people not part of
a crime syndicate or terror network find
each other and plan something that batch
insane how do you bring this up and know
for a fact that the other guy won't narc
you out
second if yours at the computer expert
why would you bother going through with
the hijacking when you clearly have the
power to hack into a private Air Marshal
Network if you could do that surely you
can hack Bank software and do the thing
from office space for Superman 3 or you
could just hack a bank and funnel the
money into a bunch of accounts exactly
as you described in the movie this
entire finale depends on a co-pilot who
all red
saw his pilot murdered trusting the word
of an alcoholic air marshal outside his
cockpit over the word of two Air Force
fighter pilots promising to shoot him in
other words both English man speaking of
which why haven't the fighter jets shot
down the hijacked airliner yet did they
read the script not only does the
incredibly heavy beverage cart stay
perfectly in the aisleway for the
sequence but also he survives this 8,000
feet ex market
bill somehow notices the gun before it's
even in plain sight and finds a way to
jump up catch it and shoot the bad guy
all in one motion guy who already had a
momentary moral dilemma about his
evilness goes suddenly back to being
able so we can have an extra whammy
ending thing oh that's fine it was only
at a minute 30 seconds three minutes ago
I'm glad they got the plane to 8,000
feet before the bomb exploded but I'm
still calling bullshit on any ending
happening from here on in that doesn't
involve most everyone on that plane
dying and that's what you get for
requesting the window seat another
little girl to cancer I mean an airplane
crash oh oh you are really testing my
patience now yet in an unbelievable
twist the suspected hijacker US Air
Marshal bill Marx turned out to be the
hero there is no way the news got ahold
of the real story of this hijacking that
fast we're gonna need that money back
what money
take care agent Marx King what vicarious
daughter this movie as with all movies
is best ended with the hint of a
romantic future out of nowhere
[Music]
the Repsol has always been for loading
and unloading there's never stopping in
a white zone
don't tell me which so much for stopping
and which zone is foreboding don't start
off with your white zone oh then I got
your attention now ma'am sorry I don't
understand
Cuddy's sake hey hey Oh stewardess I
speak John oh good
he said that he's in great pain and he
wants to know if you can help me oh so
you've never heard of the prophecy no or
the special no no I
liar I watch a lot of cop shows on TV
isn't there supposed to also be a isn't
there supposed to be a good cop are you
security and I speak of it
never play roulette always bet on black